allez comme promis dans les titres on
prend maintenant la direction de
chartres la chapelle sainte et mans
accueille jusqu'à début juin une
exposition surprenante des oeuvres d'art
composer avec des coquilles d'oeuf elles
sont signées à nathalie cholet qui
révélation 2019 du grand palais à paris
découverte signé julie poste-là qui
disait le pape
la couleur noire fait penser à soulage
les formes rondes à des obsidiennes
sculpté ce ne sont pourtant ni des
pierres volcaniques ni des galets de
marbre noir mais déco qui de pente et
assemblés en chasser au milieu des
morceaux d'or et deux verres de couleur
les créations à la fois figurative et
symboliques comme cette toile suspendue
intitulé screen ou pau en anglais c'est
tout le travail de recherche
effectivement à la fois de dinde a rendu
d'une peau qui pourraient une peau
d'animal et puis le côté souple donc
c'est sûr une sur une toile qui gardent
justement l'élasticité de la peau
ces trente oeuvres ont été créées par
nathalie cholet qu une mosaïste installé
en haute garonne elle s'est inspirée du
rand kacou un art traditionnel asiatique
qu'elle a découvert lors d'un voyage en
thaïlande en revalorisant cette
ressource l'artiste s'inscrit ici dans
la pure mosaïque contemporaine le
mosaïste contemporain n'est pas
contraint par un matériau il va se
permettre d'utiliser tous types de
matériaux donc on va retrouver
d'une incrustation de tissus de plume de
métal de tout ce qu'on veut
l'idée c'est qu'on est quand même sur la
découpe une des clowns qui demande
beaucoup de patience et de délicatesse
l'artiste joue aussi sur les reflets de
lumière avec les teintes brillantes ou
mates entre la fragilité de l'oeuf et la
force de l'oeuvre entre la sobriété du
noir et la puissance de l'or nathalie
cholet qui sublime le trivial pour
renouveler l'art de la mosaïque